what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting blindly i've never seen
this
to dating advice um on tick tock from
women in their 30s to women in their 20s
so i want to see if like any of this is
any good
um do not forget to subscribe to the
channel bring that notification
bell i'm trying to hit 20 000
subscribers as you guys know and that
way you're gonna be notified of my daily
videos
okay i'm about to start this advice
would you give to women that are in
their 20s what's something that you wish
you would if someone tells you that
people are talking about you behind your
back no they weren't that person was
you were not supposed to look like other
people you're supposed to look like the
best version of yourself and i'm so
sorry to tell you unfortunately your
natural hair color is probably the best
hair color for you
i actually agree with that i think you
waste people waste so much money dying
their hair
back and forth people are gonna tell you
not to take nudes and that's really good
advice but if you're gonna take nudes
just make sure that they're so high
quality you would be totally okay with
the whole world seeing them
because when you're in your 20s
sometimes that's okay those are okay
pictures to live forever just make sure
you're vetting them that way
i know i don't know how to feel
oh try to save that for your husband
we're not taking your makeup off at the
end of the night because you were still
snapchatting and facetiming men and
that's okay
what i need you to do is just take off
the foundation girl put a filter
like the blush all the stuff on your
skin put lotion on you can leave your
eyebrows and your eye makeup on it's at
the very end of the night
if you meet cool older people who you
want to emulate make friends with them
work hard and party hard i swear to god
just work hard party hard i know that's
an annoying phrase but do it also
unfounded i feel like when you don't
wear a bra it makes your boobs sag so
don't do that
huh okay i don't what advice would you
give to women that are in their 20s
what's something that you
oh i've been waiting for this question
one start using anti-aging skincare
now don't think cause you're 20 you too
young you are not too young this is the
perfect time
i started using anti-aging skincare when
i was 22. i'll be 36
in june oh she looks good 36 where girl
right here
two party it up travel hang out kick it
as much as possible
is that her that's her right hand so i
can't see if she's married or not
stamina to do it now
when you get into your 30s that stamina
will drop and you will still travel you
will still go out
it's not as much as you do in your 20s i
would not give the advice to young girls
to go out as much as you can i'd say
find
things that you're passionate about and
like to do like more than go out
three if you are not married right now
or not engaged
do not get married in your 20s get
married in your 30s
i got married the first time in my 20s
one star wouldn't recommend
wasn't even just the person i married it
was i'm still young and i want to be out
and be great
you ain't working out start working out
now okay
um the two i really i would not
recommend girls wait till their 30s to
get married i think that puts you in a
position where like
you you have like a time crunch and
nobody wants to feel like they have like
no time i do agree with the workout
oh my gosh if i could tell my high
school self to just maintain
maintain your body do not oh my god just
maintain what you have
actually would prevent your body from
pop blocking and dropping on you
monitor your health diseases don't care
how old you are let me know if you got
more questions women that are 30 and
above
what advice would you give to it's going
to be really irritating to keep having
to listen to the beginning
okay i love this one best advice i got
in my 20s was to be the thermostat not
the thermometer
when you walk into a room set the bar
set the temperature set the tone
don't react to everybody yeah i agree
with this i don't like it when people
say like
match that person's energy because i
feel
you should you should be
you regardless of what other people are
doing 30 and above
what advice would you give to women that
are in their 20s
save your money jessica i'm 31 it's bite
me in the ass right now
get a credit card good good advice my
dad always told me never to get a credit
card because you'll put yourself in debt
[ __ ] that get a credit card as soon as
you are able never let it get higher
than 30
and pay it on time every single month
boost your credit so when you're in your
30s and you're ready to buy a house you
[ __ ] can
if you don't have kids or you live in a
situation where it's possible
travel go everywhere [ __ ]
you got a tiny one you got a little
toddler take that [ __ ] with you
go
see the world then come back and settle
not settle for less
settle down plant roots baby and please
for the love of god where relationships
are concerned remember one thing if you
never take any other advice from me
take this never accept love from someone
else that is not as deeply as you love
yourself
if that [ __ ] makes you cry one
time and makes you
question how much they love you makes
you feel insecure if they don't love you
like you love you
next what if
see okay i agree with this advice but
the problem is sometimes i could see
girls like leaving after one fight or
like taking something the wrong way
so it makes me a little bit cautious to
say okay if he makes you cry once like
leave
like i don't know should happen
sometimes and you have to work through
it advice would you give to women
i do i do agree like the person that you
love like should
have you know those feelings towards you
that are in there
so glad you asked both professionally
and
personally the number one piece of
advice that i've ever received and that
i have given
is very simple do not hold yourself
hostage
being imprisoned by the narrative that
either you
brought into or the narrative that you
created for
yourself i know that it's really
important to create
goals for yourself to have a plan for
your future to have vision and then to
do everything in alignment to that
but when i tell you that nothing in my
life has planned out the way that i
thought it would
but that everything has worked together
for my good and even though i don't see
the purpose and everything i know that
it is a part of god's plan
trust that trust that trust that
all of god's promises are going to
happen for you it may not be in the way
you thought it might not be at the time
you thought
but it'll happen so i i don't agree some
people it doesn't work out for i think
if you're following god and doing the
right things
um obviously like i do believe god like
blesses you
uh however i do think that the church
has this culture of like
don't be proactive in dating especially
for women and i
i don't see that so much like if you're
not
going to places to meet like men you
want to potentially date how do you
expect to meet them trust the process
trust the process you can be free to
enjoy the process and learn from the
products that are 30 and above
what advice would you give to women that
are in the
hands down best advice i got and i'm 41
years old was from my grandmother
she told me when you get married you're
going to be your husband's wife and
he'll know you as your wife
for your kids when you have them they're
going to know you as their mom
but your best friend your really good
girlfriends will always know you as you
so we know where the bodies are buried
i'm 20 something years in with mine so
i'd say
value those female friendships ladies
damn
damn that's true i never thought about
it like that
damn so to my women that are 30 and
above
what advice would you give to women
don't date men
if you do don't put in too much effort
they're not going to appreciate it
anyway your coochie can be used as bait
but your mind is the real weapon that's
the one that's gonna go in for the kill
that little voice inside of you listen
to it because it's trying to tell you
something
shut your mouth and listen you will be
able to learn a lot more with your mouth
closed and your ears open
and last but not least i would have to
say
play stupid you'll be surprised of how
many people will steal from somebody
that they think is blind
wow who she seems
i forget you guys tell me that i
shouldn't say who hurt you for some
reason but
that that was my first thought when i
heard her talk
play stoop i don't know why you would
invest that much time and like
trying to figure out the dark side of
people and don't date men
oh my gosh men that are 30 and above
what advice would you give to women that
are in there
well first of all i'm still not claiming
30 and above but i have some advice
anyway
for all you 20 somethings out there
i think you're supposed to have
everything figured out already what
career by 20-something
married by 20-something first kid by
20-something
no one expects you to have all that
figured out yet
it's okay if you if you don't um
if you do great more power to you but
take your time it's okay
most people don't have it figured out in
their 20s yet
what is
i don't know the problem here's the
problem with that advice
women have a time frame like you only
have
until you're 35 to have kids and that's
the problem with the like take your time
advice is as a woman you don't always
have time what advice would you give to
women that are in their 20s
if you find yourself feeling like you're
teaching a robot how to love
run away fast if they don't know what
their own emotions are or how to express
them you're not going to be the one to
teach them
if they what does that mean if they
don't know what their emotions are you
aren't gonna be the one to teach them
make you feel stupid
or lesser than in any way run away fast
you are not stupid they just get off and
feeling like they're better than you
she seems like she's been hurt if you
like something that they don't like and
instead of saying i don't like that
they say that thing is bad run away fast
your thing is not bad
they're just trying to cut down your
self-esteem so you're less likely to
leave them
because they huh
i know they don't deserve you and they
don't
if you find yourself anxious all the
time run away fast
if you find yourself missing who they
were in the beginning for a pretty long
time
run away fast if they make a lot of
grandiose claims or promises in the very
beginning run away fast
see this is the problem with what she's
saying it's coming from a place
of being hurt like these are all
bad signs like if you've been hurt like
i hate the word love bombing right cause
they'll say like
if someone love bombs you to run but
here's the thing like
50 years ago people got married after
like a month
like i remember my grandpa said that he
was going to marry my grandma after a
month
and you could say that's love bombing in
2020 if it doesn't work out
but what if it does and i'm not saying
to like be
be you know completely blind and idiotic
about it but
she's clearly coming from a place of
being hurt you are literally the hottest
that you will ever be
and you would regret it forever if you
wasted these years on a piece of [ __ ]
you just would all right that's good
advice that's actually good advice so
it's about women
i think every girl probably has
you know something that they regret like
wasting
time 30 and above what advice would you
i'll be 55 in june my advice to women in
their 20s is to choose you
choose your love choose your life choose
your hopes choose your dreams
always choose you
ah i always choose you that's very like
20 20
me first i mean i definitely think you
should choose you when it comes to who
you date
like choose what you want what you value
um but
i don't know and you have kids and stuff
you really can't choose you
first but let me know in the comments if
you guys agree
or you disagree let me know what i
should react to next time
don't forget to subscribe bring that
notification bell i'll talk to you guys
next time